[Applaudissements]
notre vidéo
une famille leurs goûts leurs couleurs
excuse moi où il ya tous les noix non
non à la bourse savez quoi admis au
second groupe
ça va venir tu vas passer un week-end en
herbe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
-
socrates même si pas que la seule chose
que je sais c'est que je ne sais rien
on y croit les gars là bas
[Musique]
seize élèves bravo à ceux qui ont le bac
j'ai un mec
bonsoir c'est bien c'est bon à dour
festival
ça veut dire quoi au second ça veut dire
tu vas passer un week-end ou merde
désolé pour ceux qui sont au rattrapage
hop hop hop chacun son tour légalement
en fait il va en avoir besoin de points
on va faire comment nous conte la
bagnole vous êtes d'un bouquin vous que
je vais devenir un goût on y rajoute à
ça c'est pourquoi cette année on y va
premier arrivé premier servi
il joue
j'ai eu c'est vous les a dans l'est elle
resta longtemps
yum il va se retirer doigts du cul il va
bosser tout le week-end d'accord ok tous
sont l'enfant qui devient
[Applaudissements]
on y croise des galas n'est pas
vers font romeu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attends tu es sûr que tu sécurité ça toi
socrates ne dit il pas que la seule
chose que je sais c'est que je ne sais
rien mais la vodka jamais cru comprendre
y